bring in the loafers I'm pulling it off
my foot today we're talking about Bass
Weejuns bass region the bass region is
actually the original loafer it was
introduced in 1939 and then quickly
became a major staple on college
campuses so you know you'll see like old
photo is a Ivy League kids like walking
around and they're all wearing Bass
Weejuns
the same goes for like JFK and James
Dean its 2018 on some level the bass
region is still hotter than ever I think
it's a shoe that's like had many
iterations and has culturally been
relevant like time and time and time
again which i think is why it's kind of
cool right now in this era of just like
style mashup we call it the wild style
era the more you mix things together the
more interesting it gets it's a new this
shoe sort of represents that idea why is
it called a loafer it's an extremely
lazy shoe if you're an extremely lazy
human being you can actually put a loaf
around with just about anything and look
good
how many pairs of loafers do our own I
own more than 10 and less than a hundred
funny story I just got these loafers
last week it's my first pair of loafers
these are babies forced loafers loafers
are great especially we like what I'm
wearing right now because I'm having a
pair of sweat pants right but if you can
pull it off it's a pair of sweat pants
that can work with the pair of loafers
they make everything else look a little
dressier they take an outfit like this
and they make it look like I tried a
little bit but I can also break these
out with a suit and it makes a suit look
a little bit less stuffy most of the
time that's super comfortable and
they're really good to fly in because
you just slipping more and slip them off
when you're going through TSA shout out
to the hard-working people at TSA I wear
them just like I would a pair of vans or
converse or Stan Smith's to me it's like
a super casual shoe like beat them
around lamb with Levi's wearing with
shorts the more you wear them in the
better they get I think it looks really
nice
but if you beat it up it like also looks
pretty job I'll wear them for like six
months and like not shine them and they
look like super gnarly and crazy and
they look and I'm shined and they can
like you know I could wear them to like
a wedding or something
[Music]
these bass region babies only sent me
back 110 dollars which is nice that's a
bargain price I mean it's hard to find a
really good quality hard bottom shoe the
perfect marriage of the thing to me is
like the most quality that you can get
for the lowest price and then you find a
few things that are in that like perfect
zone and that's what we jeans have
always been it's also like a price where
you could just you know you buy a pair
you run them into the ground you just
buy another pair when it comes to socks
and loafers
you should definitely never wear a
notion of socks it's the only like hard
and fast rule I'm actually wearing socks
and peas hey no shows no show socks are
just evil no show socks are bogus it's
pretty easy to wear them without socks
and you don't get blisters it doesn't
get too hot but I go back and forth
I'm definitely Pro socks when it comes
to loafers I don't mind you getting a
little crazy with your sock choices
going to the club or something and bring
some periwinkle socks or something with
some loafers I'll support that energy
people called penny loafers because for
some reason on college campuses there
was a trend of putting pennies in little
coins font here I guess how do I feel
about people shoving a penny into the
loafers it's not really my vibe I opted
out penny was especially with the black
and white because you get that pop of
white in that slot right there which is
kind of like to me makes it that's what
you want the thing that I've heard that
people do is they try to get pennies
from their birth year I am down with the
penny trend but I can't find pennies
from 1993 so if you have any like mail
them to me or something I went with a
penny and P loafers cuz I don't you know
as a minimalist and a futurist I don't
believe in pennies
to me loafers are like a wardrobe staple
I own a bunch they go with anything you
wear any type of occasion any type of
wardrobe these take a Loki outfit and
lift it up they take a Heike outfit show
it out I think people who aren't like
the super style obsessed they get the
beauty of loafers loafers are basically
the the sort of optimal summer shoe what
I like to do is actually wear them with
bathing suits and stuff do not be afraid
of wearing your bass regions to the
beach they'll get sandy you'll never be
able to get the sand out but that's just
the way it is a lot of guys may already
own a pair of loafers or a pair of boat
shoes but I would say try the black and
white try something different try a
different color try a different fabric
and wear them with something you never
thought you wear will loafers with and
that's like that's my style tip right
there wear loafers was something that
you totally wouldn't think you'd ever
wear loafers way
[Music]